and the meeting is live streaming now
right then so decision
committee has given careful
consideration to the application and all
of the written and verbal evidence
presented including the objection notice
from environmental health
the committee notes that the venue is
not a licensed premises and therefore no
conditions can be attached to a
temporary event notice
the committee is sensitive to the fact
that the event is due to be held in a
marquee in a garden of a property in a
built-up residential area with sheltered
accommodation at the other end of the
footpath in this locality
and committee was also mindful of the
fact that up to 80 persons could
generate a considerable amount of noise
there is also the potential for people
to linger once music stopped at midnight
the committee was also aware that car
door slamming late at night could cause
disturbance to local
residents during the hearing the
applicant presented all evidence of
their proven track record in holding
simner events in marquis in residential
gardens
they also confirmed that the marquee
would be lined and heated with the doors
closed for the majority of the time
they also confirmed the hourly noise
checks would be conducted at the
property with sound levels recorded by a
decibel meter
they further come further confirmed so
that they would be able if necessary to
reduce the decibel level on the night in
addition they confirmed that neighbours
in close proximity would be attending
the party
the applicants confirmed that a member
of staff would monitor the car monitor
the parking and would ensure that no
driveways were blocked and the parking
was considerate
the committee were also mindful of the
fact
that this is a one-off event and that
the occupants of 43 to noon and way
could hold the event without the need
for a contemporary event notice the
operation
of the event by an ex by experienced
events company would offer a greater
degree of control
for these reasons the committee does not
consider that a counter notice would
assist in promoting the licensing
objective of presenting of public
nuisance and therefore consider that the
licensable objectives as stated in the
notice should be allowed
the committee would also would like to
emphasize to the applicants the
importance of monitoring car parking at
the beginning and then and the end of
the event
and of the need to regularly monitor
sound levels at the property for the
duration of the event
this concludes the hearing thank you all
very much
so hopefully enjoy the 21st birthday
thank you very much we will